let's see I've only been scared three
times in my life
this was one of them
[Music]
I've been married for almost 10 years
and a cop for almost 12. Captain you got
a minute go away
you ever hear of the Gemini Lounge we
got stacks of vials On These Guys these
are mobsters I'm going to cover you have
to Disappear Completely
and if I was going to do it at all I
would have to do it right
get this guy whatever he wants all right
Bourbon please
please
you sure you're in the right place
having a good time my guys
great bunch of guys did you ever kill
anybody
everything is so clear when you look
back at it
but in situations like this
you do what you have to do
I don't know what's going on in your
head I don't like the way you're acting
it's just me okay
really tells me good things about you
it's with the long face
I'll let you in my ear for a bit
these guys are not stupid everything is
under control
you're getting too close
just let it go
[Music]
sweet dreams Bobby
foreign